[Music]
the European Parliament elected David
Maria Sansone
as its new president after two rounds of
voting so solely a 63 year old Italian
former journalist was put forward while
the Progressive Alliance of socialists
and Democrats Shibata Remo in cm / on
parlamento moderno you trasparent
eco-sustainable a HSC belay I cheated
him three other candidates stood for the
post
skaar Keller from the Green Party serie
Rago from the European United Left
Nordic Green left and yan zacchara deal
from the European conservatives and
reformists the European People's Party
the biggest political group in the
Parliament did not propose a candidate
sassily was a vice president of the
European Parliament from 2014 to 2019 in
the first round of voting he garnered
325 votes just seven votes short of a
majority but clinched the post in the
second round with 345 out of 667 valid
votes speaking after his election he
called for a strong union to resist
mounting populism yamadera LeFort Sudhir
Allah sorry no slow process of
integration cambiado la nostra neon
paren durla capacity responder a a modo
de Fortaleza gents a dentistry cheated
in a perder esposa very al alluro
preocupaciones n prey to diffusion
Sancho his Merry Men
[Applause]
[Music]